pour vous pensez que les garçons sont
mieux payés que les films oui la
différence entre moi et les autres
hommes pouvaient aller jusqu'à 1000
euros par mois près de 50 ans séparent
ces deux archives et le constat reste le
même en france les femmes gagnent moins
que les hommes
selon les données les plus récentes elle
touchait 16 7% de moins que leurs
homologues masculins
jamais les hommes peuvent dire l'égalité
salariale
un combat qui prend son essor après la
seconde guerre mondiale et alors que de
plus en plus de femmes accèdent au
marché du travail
françois mitterrand alors candidat à la
présidentielle en fait l'un de ses
thèmes de campagne
c'était en 1965 en 1958 le salaire
féminin et le salaires masculins étaient
très proches l'un de l'autre
aujourd'hui ils sont les plus éloignés
dans l'europe occidentale et au
détriment des femmes de telle sorte
qu'on peut dire sans risque de se
tromper à l'égard du salaire la femme
est considérée comme un être inférieur
alors que son rendement est le plus
souvent égale 1972 première avancée en
france
la loi instaure l'égalité de
rémunération entre hommes et femmes à
travail égal mais les écarts perdure
l'une des raisons c'est que les femmes
accèdent difficilement aux postes les
mieux rémunérés prenons l'exemple du
secteur privé
le salaire net moyen des femmes restent
largement inférieur à celui des hommes
28 28 59 % de différence en 1977 deux
cadres sont les écarts de salaires ans
peuvent aller de 500 800 voire 1000
francs par mois un même travail pour une
même qualification professionnelle
puis 24 57% 1987 et 22 98% 1996
l'écart se réduit y'a pas de raison à
travail égal salaire égal
et en plus les fans quand on rentre à la
maison il ya autre chose à faire jusqu'à
descendre à 16 80 % de différence en
2016 bref ça baisse mais l'égalité
salariale ce n'est toujours pas ça
pourquoi une femme de nos jours ces
écarts sont même plus fort selon les
secteurs
en 2018 chez les employés les femmes
gagnent en moyenne 6 % de moins que les
hommes
les ouvrières ces 15% un pourcentage qui
monte jusqu'à 18% chez les cadres
supérieurs
[Musique]